thank you so much president dahus
distinguished guests dear friends it is
an honor for me
to open this 10th anniversary edition of
the state of the union conference
indeed every year around europe day
florence becomes the
center of our union and there could be
no better place than florence to
celebrate this year's europe day
florence is the city of renaissance
the place where it all started a new
beginning of arts and science
after the great plague of the late
middle ages
and from florence the spirit of the
renaissance
spread to the rest of europe too
la storia de europa et astoria
di renaissimenti europe is a story of
new beginnings
after every crisis came a european
renaissance
and this is what europe needs in our day
and age
this is our responsibility to end the
pandemic
and to shape a new beginning for europe
europe is able to overcome crises
and to deliver for the future of its
citizens
and this is what i would like to talk
about today
on the basis of two exemplary topics
the pandemic and climate change
yes we all heard the nagging
questions especially in the first month
of this pandemic
aren't nation states better equipped to
fight this crisis
isn't our union of 27 too slow to react
aren't our processes to cumbersome
and our stakeholders to diverse
today i am here to say
europe has proven these claims wrong
europe has demonstrated that a union of
democracies
can deliver in times of crisis
for its own citizens and for the rest of
the world
under huge pressure we europeans stood
by our values
and on top of this we demonstrated that
even in times of a global pandemic
we are able to tackle forcefully
other great challenges of our time
and ladies and gentlemen let's have a
closer look at it
the european union was not designed
to deal with health issues or fighter
pandemic
i remember very vividly the early days
of the pandemic
and i remember the call for europe
coming from italy
the people of italy demanded that europe
stepped in
they demanded european solidarity and
coordination
and they were right italy was right
europe had to step in and that is what
we did
some member states had introduced export
bans on medical equipment
some member states had closed their
borders
we europe restored the free movement of
goods in our single market
we made sure that the bans were lifted
and medical equipment
could get to where it was needed
and most importantly we decided
to procure vaccines together in our
union
this was the right decision
even if there were doubts especially at
the beginning of this year
i don't even want to imagine what it
would have meant
if some large member states had secured
their vaccines
while the rest all the small and
medium-sized member states
went empty-handed just think
of the consequences for our internal
market
for our european unity
indeed i'm convinced that economically
it would have made no sense whatsoever
with such a deeply integrated single
market
and politically it would have
torn our union apart
today the enormous gains delivered by
our unity
are obvious for everybody it is clear
that our european vaccination campaign
is
a success because what counts
is neither the blaring headlines in
certain countries abroad
nor the social media stunts of so-called
vaccine
diplomacy what
counts is the steadily increasing
daily delivery of vaccines
to our people and to the world
let me give you some figures
so far about 200 million doses of
vaccines
have been distributed inside the
european union
200 million these are enough vaccines to
vaccinate more than
half of europe's adult population at
least once
neither china nor russia come even close
right now as i speak we are vaccinating
30
europeans every second
this means that since the beginning of
this speech
more than 12 000 europeans have received
a jab
by now we're almost used to hearing such
figures every day
but europe has never seen anything like
this a mass vaccination campaign
on a continental scale
and this is happening because an entire
continent has mobilized
from small hospitals to massive
vaccination centers
the campaign is on in all corners of our
union
today we are vaccinating more than 3
million europeans per day
and the progress in europe is gaining
speed by the day
so i am confident that we will be able
to reach our goal
to deliver enough doses to have 70
percent of european adults
vaccinated already in july
the us has a similar goal and this shows
how much our vaccination campaigns are
aligned by now
some might say well countries like the
us and the united kingdom have been
faster at the beginning
but i say europe achieved this success
while remaining open to the world
while others keep their vaccine
production for themselves
europe is the main exporter of vaccines
worldwide
so far more than 200 million doses of
vaccines produced in europe
have been shipped to the rest of the
world
europe exports as much vaccines
as it delivers to its own citizens and
to be clear
europe is the only democratic region in
the world
that exports vaccines on a large scale
the european union is also ready
to discuss any proposal that address
the crisis in an effective
and pragmatic manner and that's why
we are ready to discuss how
the us proposal for waiver on
intellectual property protection
for coveted vaccines could help achieve
that
objective in the short run however
we call upon all vaccine producing
countries
to allow exports and to avoid measures
that disrupt supply chains
exports from europe go to more than 90
countries
kovacs included shipments goes
go to our close allies like canada
and the uk our dear british friends have
received a total of
28 million doses from the continent so
far
even 72 million doses have been shipped
to japan
and also many millions to our friends in
singapore in mexico or colombia just to
name a few
europe is nowadays the pharmacy of the
world
openness and fairness
are europe's trademark in the world and
we do
take pride in this
all of this was not self-evident
especially at the start of this crisis
you remember some have chosen to isolate
others have tried
to use a difficult situation to leverage
geopolitical gains
i have never believed in this approach
if the virus keeps spreading in india or
in africa in brazil or russia
it is a serious risk for all of us
it is the breeding ground for escape
variants
and we know that no one is safe until
everyone is safe
and of course this is also true when
planning ahead for the future
because we already must prepare now for
this next stage of this pandemic
we have seen that to fight a pandemic
successfully
preparedness and speed are key
we need booster jabs to reinforce and
prolong immunity
we will need to vaccinate children and
teenagers at a certain point in time
and we might have to adapt and reproduce
vaccines if an escape variant occurs
and this is for europe and for the world
and for all this we need increased
production capacities
right here in europe and this is why
i'm happy to tell you that we are close
to signing a new contract with biontech
pfizer
it will deliver 1.8 billion doses of
vaccines
between year end and 2023
and other contracts will follow
and this shows clearly that our
investments are paying off
that from early on we invested in a
promising
but completely new technology the mrna
and in the ingenuity of scientists
like uber shaheen and islam teurici
today mrna vaccines are the backbone of
our vaccination campaign
and the centerpiece of europe's
preparedness strategy
this is our common insurance policy
against the next wave of covet 19
and i want us to be ahead of the curve
and the whole world needs to be ahead of
the curve too
and this is also why i have proposed
holding
a g20 global health summit
i will co-host it with prime minister
draghi in rome
later this month because we must
now move from the ad hoc solutions of
this year
towards a sustainable system
a system that works for the whole world
because we all know that viruses know no
borders
in rome we want to discuss international
cooperation
in health emergencies including with
ngos foundations and civil society
these are new alliances for better
solutions
yes i know preparedness comes at a cost
but the cost of preparedness is tiny
compared to the cost of inaction
the world needs a new beginning on
health policy and our health
renaissance begins in rome
ladies and gentlemen
this crisis exposed our fragility
the fragility of our health
the fragility of our livelihoods
but today we emerge from this fragility
with a new found purpose
we are reshaping our continent for
decades ahead
because while fighting this pandemic
our union has started to do something
it has never done before on this scale
with the strong backing of 27 member
states
the european commission is raising
capital
on the international markets this
empowers our union to invest
billions in a badly needed joint
recovery
and in our common priorities investments
and reforms
the plan is called next generation eu
it is worth 750 billion euros
it's the largest recovery package in
europe since the marshall plan
and it can trigger a european
renaissance
the priorities of next generation eu are
set in stone
the resilience of our single market
digitalization and the european green
deal
because climate change is the
crisis that will stay with us
once the pandemic is defeated
i don't have to tell you about
desertification
and droughts extreme weather situations
and floods the loss of biodiversity
and dying forests
yes we have a daunting task ahead of us
climate change is happening
science is clear
people in europe are already suffering
because of climate change
and again we have the choice we either
pay the costs
of inaction or we act
and i prefer the letter it will not be
easy
it will take all our ingenuity endurance
investment and courage
but we have the mandate and the
responsibility to succeed
and together i am convinced
we can do this
with our european green deal we are
determined
to become the first climate neutral
continent
in 2050. i have
just experienced at the international
climate conference on earth day how
powerful our message is
with its climate ambition europe is
clearly
leading the way and it is great to see
that others
are joining us south africa
south korea japan
china just to name a few major economies
all embarking on their way to a net zero
future
and it is particularly encouraging
to have the united states with president
biden
back into the paris agreement
yes the commitments they are out there
but these commitments now have to be
backed up
by real action and measurable targets
only what can be measured is done
and here again europe leads the way
we just agreed to engrave our
commitments
in europe's first ever climate law
in addition we will present the long
series
of legislative proposals before the
summer
in order to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions
by at least 55 by 2030
we call this huge package fit for 55.
it spans an arc from for example
enhanced emission trading system
to renewables like clean hydrogen
and clear rules for green finance for
example
it is flanked by next generation eu
our huge recovery investment
one-third of next generation eu is
earmarked
for the european green deal so
we have the strategy we have the laws
and we have the resources and we have
the sense of urgency
both domestically and increasingly
globally
we invite our american friends to join
us
in these next concrete steps to net zero
emissions
let's create a powerful transatlantic
alliance
for climate neutrality by 2050
ladies and gentlemen
a few kilometers from florence
there is a small village called barbiana
on a hill in barbiana there is a small
countryside school
back in the 1960s
a young teacher don lorenzo milani
wrote two simple words in english
on a wall in that school
i care
he told his students that those were the
two
most important words they needed to
learn
i care i care means
i take responsibility
and this year millions of europeans said
i care with their actions
they volunteered they helped a neighbor
need
or simply they wore a mosque to protect
people around them
in this year of pandemic and beyond
this must be europe's motto too
i care we care
this is the most important lesson that i
hope
we can learn from this crisis
it's a lesson about europe
we care for the weakest among us
we care for our neighbors
we care for our planet
and we care for future generations
this is why we will be officially
launching the conference on the future
of europe
on sunday on europe day
the years ahead will once again be a
defining period for our european union
the next european renaissance
and the outcome of the conference will
only be as good
as the ideas and visions of people like
you
so i count on your contributions
we vale europe and thank you for your
attention